literally there were 60 or 80 SWAT
members in all in flat jackets and hoods
and you know their faces covered the
whole deal machine guns it was like
something you'd seen in movies you know
basically you're playing game bang on
the door you know extremely loud and the
next thing you know you know you hear
the crash of a battering ram hitting my
front door in March of 2013
Steve Oates's home in Goodyear Arizona
was stormed by police SWAT and DEA for
having a marijuana grow room in the
guest house a grow room that he thought
was legal after his doctor recommended
medicinal marijuana for chronic back
pain Oates says dispensaries were still
few and far between at the time the only
way to really you know to get the
medicine you needed was you know through
Craigslist or word-of-mouth of those
kind of things which I really wasn't
comfortable with so I felt like the next
alternative was to grow it ourselves so
I you know applied to become for
cultivation rights and it was a pretty
seamless easy process
Oates had met a few other patients who
were in the same boat and they started
growing together at Oates's home during
the raid Oates was caught with more
marijuana than what his card permitted
because he had his fellow growers supply
as well he ended up pleading guilty to
possessing under two pounds of marijuana
you know I heard it from the judge the
prosecutor my attorney everybody else if
you take this to trial and you lose
you're going to prison three to five
years here take this deal well what does
a guy do I have to work for a living I
support a family I can't afford to go to
prison for three to five years the
conviction ended up being the smallest
price that Oates had to pay Goodyear PD
wanted to go after his bank account
through civil asset forfeiture that's
when the government can seize property
and finances that they suspect have a
connection to illegal activities like
drug dealing or money laundering but
they sue the property instead of the
person so there doesn't even have to be
a related conviction there should be
some type of relation between the event
your actions and the property itself
that they're trying to forfeit right so
what in this case they don't have any
proof or any evidence that the the
operator trying to forfeit is related to
the crime of his possession of marijuana
for sale Oates's lawyer John Moore says
that the Maricopa County Attorney
declined the case because there was no
evidence but that didn't stop goodyear
police they shopped it out to the
attorney general's office who got on
board and slapped oats with four hundred
and fifty five thousand dollars in
forfeiture the Attorney General's Office
declined reasons requests for comment
that's what they're claiming is that the
market value of the sales that he
allegedly made was four hundred fifty
five thousand dollars it's just that you
know just a ridiculous number that they
threw out there so they could come take
all my stuff seize my bank accounts and
and try to keep it Steve kept immaculate
track of all of his grow that shows that
he received seventeen thousand dollars
he does not contest that he started to
grow in June of two thousand twelve and
between the time the grow starting and
him finishing in March of 2013 he had
approximately twenty five thousand
dollars in costs these numbers indicate
that he lost money and was not selling
for profit but even though the state has
these records and no witnesses to say
otherwise it's not enough with a civil
forfeiture the burden actually shifts to
the defendant where they have to prove
their innocence we have to show by
preponderance of the evidence that's
this money that they are trying to
forfeit came from legal means there is
no such thing as and it's until proven
guilty now that I can attest to you know
the prosecutors there to prosecute
someone straight out now Oates is
fighting to get his assets back he says
they have taken far more than the four
hundred and fifty five thousand at this
point if you include you know bank
account seized you know bond money that
seized property they've taken damage to
the house is over six hundred thousand
right now that doesn't include the you
know sixty thousand that I'm into
attorneys for and I guess I would rather
spend every dollar of it on an attorney
than just let them have it
Oates even has to worry about his future
assets because they may still be subject
to the original seizure warrant I still
do not have a bank account you know
everything I do has to be with you know
cash and money orders and you know and
you know talk somebody into cashing a
check for me and doing it you know it's
a it's a it's a pain in the butt right
now it says the means to keep fighting
but that's not always the
case when dealing with law enforcement
especially in Arizona they have time on
their side they have all the resources
in the world they have nothing to lose
and everything to gain you know I'm the
only one that has anything to lose the
difference between Arizona and other
states is that Arizona permits law
enforcement to utilize seized funds to
fund their own departments as well as to
pay for salaries so they have a direct
incentive to go after personal assets of
citizens more adds that this isn't just
a problem for those directly subject to
forfeiture it's a problem for the
community as a whole their focus is on
raising revenues instead of actual law
enforcement self so in this case you
have Steve Oates
who was growing medical marijuana and
instead of going after real drug dealers
who are transporting across state lines
or criminal gangs that are creating
great crime and personal injury to
people they're going after an individual
because they knew he had funds in his
bank account the trial will most likely
be held in the spring and until then the
oats will have to live paycheck to
paycheck if their life savings
belongings are still being held hostage
every day at about 6:30 in the morning
on and looking out the windows one under
they go back because that's the way I
understand it they could come back today
if they wanted to